LAURENCE MORONEY:
On this episode
of "Coffee with a
Googler," I'm chatting
with Will French, who works on
Google Developer Docs for Maps.
He'll tell us all
about it and stay tuned
for his superhero origin story.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So Will, you're a tech
writer here at Google,
and I understand writing
technical documentation
at Google, it's a pretty
complex process, right?
WILLIAM FRENCH: It is.
A lot goes into
documenting Google APIs.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So it's like--
I mean, we have
thousands of products
and many pages for them.
How do you manage
the whole thing?
WILLIAM FRENCH: Well, we use
the same source control systems
as other Google products.
So the same types of
tools that engineers use,
technical writers use
to create and maintain
technical documentation.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So if
you're writing a doc,
it's almost like
writing source code
that gets compiled in and--
WILLIAM FRENCH: Yeah,
it's very-- very much so.
In fact, we actually
do even write some code
as tech writers.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
You write code?
WILLIAM FRENCH: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
What's the last piece of
code that you've worked on?
WILLIAM FRENCH: Let's
see, I did a sample
to demonstrate some
new API features.
A lot of the time,
tech writing samples
won't actually be published.
Sometimes they are,
but most of the time,
we just use them to make
sure everything works.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And really
makes the docs authentic
if there's good
samples in there.
WILLIAM FRENCH:
Yeah, it gives us
an in to even find problems
with code and things like that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now, you
work on the Google Maps
platform, right?
WILLIAM FRENCH: That's
right, Maps and Places APIs.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So what kind
of stuff do you do with that?
WILLIAM FRENCH: Well, I write
and maintain documentation
for the Maps iOS APIs, and
I'm responsible for all
of the Places APIs
documentation.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow,
iOS APIs, that's like--
how is-- how is that to work
with, like with Google Maps?
WILLIAM FRENCH: That was
a bit of a learning curve,
but it's actually a lot
of fun to work with.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now,
even though like--
you and I have
worked on GEO stuff
and I do GEO outreach myself.
And most of the team
is based overseas
and that kind of thing.
But you're based
here in Kirkland.
And what's it like being
a Googler in Kirkland?
WILLIAM FRENCH: Kirkland
is a wonderful facility.
It's even got a bike trail
running right through it.
So as a cyclist, I
really appreciate that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I
hear you've had some fun
adventures while you're biking.
Could you tell us
about some of them?
WILLIAM FRENCH:
Well, you're probably
referring to the bat incident.
LAURENCE MORONEY: The
bat incident, yes.
So tell the viewers about that.
WILLIAM FRENCH: Oh,
well, a couple of years
ago, I was cycling on the
Burke-Gilman Trail in Seattle.
And I had an encounter
with a flying bat.
It was flying somewhere in
the middle of the afternoon,
so he probably
shouldn't have been out.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Maybe
it was a blind bat.
No, wait, they're all blind.
WILLIAM FRENCH: Well,
I collided with him.
And in the process of moving him
out of the road, I was bitten.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So you've
been bitten by a bat?
WILLIAM FRENCH: I have.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So this sounds
like a comic book superhero
origin story.
WILLIAM FRENCH: Sort of,
except I'm still waiting
for my superpowers to arrive.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Have any of them--
do you get sonar and that
kind of stuff working?
WILLIAM FRENCH: Well, I have
an aversion to emergency rooms.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Ladies and gentlemen, we
have Batman with us.
So back to tech writing and back
to Maps and that kind of thing
then, I understand that you
work a lot with the Solutions.
So could you tell us a
little bit about Solutions
and what they do?
What good are they
for developers?
WILLIAM FRENCH:
Well, GEO Solutions
are like standard tutorials
and documentation,
and it sort of takes
it a step above
and makes a more
comprehensive offering.
So rather than
just demonstrating
how to put a marker on a
map, we'll show you that.
We'll show you how to style
the markers on the map.
We'll show you how to build
a back end to serve data to.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So one of
them is a store locator, right?
So if I own a chain
of stores, you'll
basically give me
everything that I
need to be able to build a
mapping solution around that?
WILLIAM FRENCH: Yeah, the
store locator solution, it
has a few different
flavors, actually.
And we've got a simple
store locator, which is all
based on JavaScript,
and it takes
a set, a hard coded set of
coordinates, and displays them
on a map and demonstrates
styling the markers
and how to add an info
window with custom data.
We've got a slightly
more involved version
of that called the
New York City Subway
Locator, which also involves
marker clustering and view
bounding.
So it's got some open
source libraries in there
that it uses for that.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Marker clustering
is a really cool
technology, right?
If you've ever had a map, and,
you look at it from the outside
and if you're trying to show
subway stations in New York
City, for example, there's
just too many pins,
and you can't see
any of the city.
But clustering solves that?
WILLIAM FRENCH: Clustering
solves that problem, yeah.
And there's-- basically what
it does is it breaks down pins
so that if there's a
certain number of them,
they get condensed
into one large pin.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right, and
then it's like a number--
WILLIAM FRENCH: And then
expands into individual pins.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So that's
perfect for something
like the New York subway.
How many stations do you know?
WILLIAM FRENCH: I
don't know offhand.
LAURENCE MORONEY: There's
hundreds, though, right?
WILLIAM FRENCH: Yeah, the
GEO JSON data is actually
pretty interesting to look at.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So is
that how you drive it?
So GEO JSON data gives you
the locations of these pins,
and then you cluster that?
WILLIAM FRENCH: Yeah, for
the purposes of that demo,
the data was taken from the
actual New York City subway
organization.
So that's available online,
and it's in GEO JSON format.
So with that, there's
a lot of stuff
that developers can
do using GEO JSON.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
And then the code that's
part of the solution is also
showing you how to
parse GEO JSON, right?
WILLIAM FRENCH: That's right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Which is a
useful tool in and of itself.
WILLIAM FRENCH: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So if I'm
building something-- like,
I don't own anything as
big as the New York subway.
But if I'm building
something like--
I don't know, if I have
a chain of small bakeries
or something along those lines,
the solution will guide me
in how I can have
my bakeries plotted,
how those plots can be styled,
popups, that kind of thing?
WILLIAM FRENCH:
Yeah, the solution
shows a baseline implementation
that developers can then
expand and customize.
So the code is all there for--
free for the taking
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, cool.
And I believe there are
code labs as well that'll
teach me how to do this stuff?
WILLIAM FRENCH: Yes, a
number of the solutions
also include code labs,
which are a longer,
more involved walk-through,
sort of a step-by-step tutorial.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Now, if you were to build one
of these yourself, how would
you get started?
WILLIAM FRENCH: If I
was going to create
a new solution from scratch?
LAURENCE MORONEY: No.
I mean, like, if you had a
chain of bookstores or something
like that that you wanted
to plot, how would you
get started with a solution?
WILLIAM FRENCH:
Well, for these ones,
I would simply go out
to the GitHub repo
and clone the repo for the
solution that I want to use.
So all of the code is
available on GitHub for these.
I can go out and get it.
I can run it.
I can get an API key
and deploy it myself.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So if I
want to build my own solution
to find all the bats in
Seattle that might bite me,
where would I go to get started?
WILLIAM FRENCH: Well you
would go to developers.googl
e.com/maps/solutions.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And we'll
see all your hard work there?
WILLIAM FRENCH: That's right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
So thanks very much, Will.
I've learned so much
in this episode.
And thanks, everybody,
for watching this far.
For the links to the
solutions that we spoke about,
and there are other
solutions too,
just take a look in
the description below.
And I'd love to see
what kind of things
you're going to
build on Google Maps.
Thank you very much.
And thanks again, Will.
WILLIAM FRENCH: Thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Watch out for the bats.